Have you heard of New Coke? It’s, like,
the 1980s and Coca-Cola is losing market
share to their rival, Pepsi. People like
Pepsi because it is sweeter. So they did
something kind of crazy. They changed
their formula, their big secret formula,
they changed it to make it more sweet and they
did a bunch of corporate research that came
back and it was like, “Yeah, people like this
more. More than Pepsi and more than regular
Coke.” [Ad] We gave America a choice and more
people said Coke is it. [Ad Song] It’s a hit!
So in 1985, they tell the world that they
are releasing this new formula and because
people are people, they lost their collective shit
about it, there were little protest groups. “Our
children will never know refreshment.” So yeah,
there was huge backlash and after just 79 days,
Coca-Cola announced that they were bringing back
the old Coke and it would be called Coca-Cola
Classic so that everyone knew this wasn't New
Coke. And lo and behold, Coca-Cola started
overtaking Pepsi again to become the most popular
sugary drink in the world. Congratulations,
Coca-Cola. I kind of am curious what new Coke
tastes like, but I guess I'll never know.